lays on fire everybody I got this I got
well I peed in a bottle Brian he did and
I'm in studio and he peed in a pure leaf
brewed tea bottle but it looks like a
party it does I would drink it you drank
it you fill that up because I that's not
enough for mine you don't realize how
much PP are you out doing fellas I was
in traffic and I'm like I'm gonna piss
my pants yeah on PCH I'm gonna piss my
[ __ ] pants right already get off PCH
Ocean to the right fire to the left
yeah acting in doing so Papago I at this
fairly large bottle yeah got the old
dick out yep shoved in that shirt and
it's a white remember it's a white top
yeah it's a white oh yeah hot skinny hi
hey kiddies don't fit in there man I
just get out the old baby bird yeah put
the little [ __ ] right in the in the
shoot there yeah I'm peeing I'm like oh
well this thing's filling up fast fast
fast
just four full iced tea here fast
yeah can't pinch it off no so I close
that thing up it did splash yeah I did
did splash splash all over my hands yeah
well on the jeans oh I can't stop peeing
no he's wet are my pants wet Ryan
pissed your pants and I'll soapy dumbass
Martin a little bit
well my father we're in a plane my
father used to be an amateur pilot he
used to fly a little plane so he goes I
got pissed and he goes me too and he he
pulls out a bottle of some special
people big bottle not really now my pop
is a big man he pulls out his piece and
and he's not working with the James
that's what it's old days where it's old
man right so no what no old man I've
been here a long time I'm a problem
turtle he pulls it out and I'm sitting
there was him he starts to piss
he's got khaki shorts on and he pisses
and misses the entire bottle and doesn't
really notice like I don't know probably
welcome oh you're pissing all over and
he goes ah [ __ ] and he just pissed and I
got about three drops tomorrow he's just
pissed all over the [ __ ] we got out and
he had piss honest
front end on his ass we didn't care he
didn't give a [ __ ] I was like you're
walking around with a giant your
your shorts are soaked dude these
construction workers that weren't enough
truck like when those big trucks are
driving by they saw my dick piece they
started laughing they understand what do
I so when was it's a group of girls you
got a piss when you got a piss you off
it was so cool Dennis can I fill the
[ __ ] tennis can one time oh I I need
those big like get all right I need a
milk jug
I need no empty milk jug that's lonely
carry my car especially when you got a
really pissed I'll just keep this old a
drink a coffee that's just a lot brewing
dude so back in 2017 a flight attendant
found out that the two pilots on a
flight from Phoenix to I believe it was
Oh from Pittsburgh to Phoenix set up a
toilet cam in the restroom of the
airplane so she found out because
there's a rule where if one of the
pilots needed to go to the restroom
there had to be somebody else there in
his place so it would usually be a
flight attendant one of the pilots asked
the flight attendant to come and take
his place just to sit there while he
went to the restroom because that's
protocol so this woman came and she sat
there and she saw something on an iPad
closeby where his seat was and she
thought it was odd and she saw that it
was him walking into the restroom and
then using the restroom she looked to
the other pilot and asked him what is
this is this a live camera feed from our
restroom and he said well it he was
trying to play it off as this is
Southwest's new protocol where you're
trying to like basically catch
terrorists or people trying to hide [ __ ]
and he said oh but you can't tell
anybody cuz we're it's kind of on the
down low yeah it's top secret cause she
didn't feel good about this so she
reported it and Southwest has been
trying to keep it hush because if this
got out nobody would want to yeah use
their services anymore and now she is
suing them along with her husband even
though her husband wasn't on that
particular flight he's suing as well for
$50,000 in emotional abuse 50,000 I mean
aim a little higher yeah something 9
grand for that with up for a few million
so you settle for a few no
Wow but also what kind of weight who
wants to watch me go to the bathroom
freaks there's something for everyone
that's so strange so here's the thing
but what the copilot you're in on it too
both you like this [ __ ] we're free
really gonna fly it might get me jacking
off well yeah that's you might be bored
and you want to see
well yeah kiss the plane fly themselves
these days yes all they have to deal
with is the landing and that the takeoff
in the landing that's all that's all
they're there for that's in cruise
control so these guys like to let people
take whatever dues
dude those bathrooms so small even if
you have a camera that ain't seen [ __ ]
not giant ass in there you see big back
just like this mr. giant as you can see
you see my arm like this man cleaning is
he polishing it you guys I'm just
cleaning my dick I'm just cleaning it
this poor guy this I guess this was
released it was published from the
British Medical Journal of a guy who
would get drunk without drinking alcohol
so in his stomach when you eat like
carbs yeah food high in carbs yeah it
would somehow convert to yeast and
become alcohol in his stomach so he
would be like two times over the limit
auto-brewery smaller brewery syndrome
yeah because his that his gut biome is
off so he's the ultimate keto kid he
doesn't have unless you ask you can't
have yeah he's just drunk as [ __ ] just
have a piece of toast and you're [ __ ]
up so you got a DWI on the way to work
one morning suffered a head injury in a
drunken fall and I bet nobody believes
them either yeah it's like I'm sure
buddy
yes but then they found out they did to
us and they found that he does have that
auto-brewery syndrome
yeah damn rare condition that's crazy
Tony does go to your drunk sowhat's give
that to you as it's a get sag if it's a
gift